a violent psychopath who escaped from a
Hawaii mental hospital is behind bars in
California this morning after 72 hours
on the run
Randall Saito is his name he was
arrested yesterday in Stockton
California officials say the
psychopathic predator used wads of cash
plane rides and an alias to evade police
vladimir duthiers our streaming network
cbsn has been following this story and
joins us with the latest bye good
morning good morning prosecutors
describe Saito as someone who fits the
criteria of a classic serial killer
there are many unanswered questions
about how Saito escaped and evaded
capture the way he was apprehended
seemed to involve luck as much as
detective work
Randall Saito's taste of freedom ended
Wednesday at this Northern California
gas station they all swarmed in from you
know both sides of driveway from the
back and then it was a real quiet arrest
authorities say their big break came
after Saito's cab driver recognized him
from news reports which later led to the
cab company alerting police the
company's general manager who did not
want to be identified says a driver told
him Saito wanted to travel to another
state he's on the radio saying hey I
need a price to Reno when he got
surrounded by the police the only thing
the guy in the back said was they got me
[Music]
dashcam video obtained by our Honolulu
affiliate KGMB shows Saito making his
escape from the mental hospital Sunday
using the name bill he had been held in
this facility for nearly four decades
after being acquitted by reason of
insanity for a gruesome murder Saito
paid in cash for a charter flight to
Maui he then flew to San Jose California
purchasing that ticket through
Travelocity with another alias
apparently using a hospital computer his
absence went unreported for 10 hours
leading to questions of whether he had
help
staff may have inadvertently or
purposefully neglected proper
notification of Supervisors Hawaii's
Attorney General says Saito's plan was
clearly premeditated this is something
that was not done by somebody who was a
was suffering from any sort of mental
defect and we intend to press that
argument with the court at least 7
employees at the mental hospital have
been placed on unpaid administrative
leave pending an investigation Saito now
faces a hearing in California to be
extradited back to Hawaii beyond him
yeah those employees have some questions
to answer Vlad thank you